je voudrais commencer ce speech où cette
conférence par une note d'humour
philosophique
un jour un homme vint voir socrates
s'est lui dit écoute socrates j'ai
quelque chose à te dire alors socrates
l'interrompt il lui dit mais est-ce que
ce que tu as à me dire est ce que tu as
passé ce que tu as à me dire par les
trois amis les trois amis s'exclama
l'homme très étonné oui mais dit est ce
que ce que tu as à me dire tu l'a passée
par le premier et amis de la bonté est
ce que ce que tu as tu vas me dire est
bon alors l'homme réfléchit un peu et
lui dit non pas vraiment je pense que
c'est au contraire c'est pas c'est pas
vraiment bon alors il lui dit est-ce que
ok c'est pas grave
voyant que même si tu as passé est ce
que tu as à me dire par le deuxième
famille
celui de la vérité si ce que tu vas me
dire n'est pas bon est ce qu'il est au
moins vrai alors l'homme c'est un cas un
peu il dit non je ne pense pas parce que
c'est pas vraiment moi qui a vécu la
situation m'a rapporté cette situation
alors là socrates lui dit bon alors
examinons le situe à c'est ce que tu as
à me dire si ce n'est pas bon si ce
n'est pas vrai est ce qu'il est ou moins
utiles et c'est le troisième tami alors
l'homme lui ai dit réfléchit un peu lui
dit non je ne pense pas que ça soit
utile donc socrate lui le regarde et dit
si ce que tu vas me dire n'est pas ni
bons ni vrai ni utile je préfère ne pas
le savoir et je te conseille de
l'oublier c'est pareil pour moi
quand on m'a appelé ces jeunes pleins de
talent linate mi mai
khadija aram audace et prions et anaïs
toute cette belle équipe qui a pris
l'initiative d'inviter des gens à
partager des idées et apprendre la pub
la parole publiquement j'ai hésité j'ai
hésité parce que pour moi la prise de
parole publique est une grande
responsabilité je me suis dit qu'est ce
que j'ai à dire qu'il soit bon et il est
vrai à la fois j'ai posé la question
encore sur le thème sur lequel je dois
intervenir alors gg on m'a annoncé que
c'est comment devenir une meilleure
version de toi même alors ça je me suis
dit bon devenir une mère ce ver
meilleure version de moi même est-ce que
je suis une version saas sonné pour moi
comme un slogan publicitaire et je me
sentais encore plus mal à l'aise de
d'accepter de venir et de de me déplacer
de tunis à namur pour parler d'un slogan
publicitaire
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une version de
moi même qui suis-je
d'abord qui es tu d'abord quelle version
de toi même celles qu'on a préparé pour
toi celle qu'on veut imposer celle que
compte a programmé pour être les livres
par exemple est ce qu'on peut parler de
versions de livres non je ne pense pas
les livres est-ce qu'on peut les définir
je ne pense pas on peut les résumer on
peut avoir une impression on peut avoir
une perception et pour moi les hommes
sans pareil sont ne sont pas des peut
pas les réduire à des versions non je ne
suis pas une version je suis plus qu'une
version une version ses limites et moi
je suis est limité je suis une
conscience je suis une conscience en
devenir
je ne veux pas devenir une meilleure
version mais je suis une conscience on
devenir
une conscience qui est en perpétuel
changement
une conscience du monde et je travaille
tous les jours améliorer ma conscience
du monde dans chaque rencontre que je
fais dans chaque livre que je lis dans
chaque expérience que je vis que ce soit
une expérience malheureuse ou une
expérience heureuse je me cherche je
cherche à comprendre le monde et à
m'inspirer de cette expérience pour
devenir plus en cohérence avec moi-même
d'abord et avec le monde
nous on nous élèvent depuis notre vie
notre jeunesse sur des modèles de ready
made façon d'être de réfléchir de
consommer tel produit de d'acheter telle
marque pour devenir mieux pour se sentir
mieux pour acquérir un bonheur tout est
façonné tout et domestiques et tout est
programmé pour nous rendre selon des
modèles pour avoir telle carrière et pas
tel ou tel autre pour être avec telle
personne n'est pas sept autres comme si
tout est possible d'être divisé on
négative on positive et moi ce que je
fais en travaillant sur moi même c'est
d'essayer de deux de m'éloigner le plus
possible de cette de cette force
d'opinion d'avis que les autres émettent
par rapport à vous et quand je parlais
tout à l'heure de la parole delà de
l'importance de la parole
c'est là en fait où la parole peut être
une force créatrice ul peut aussi être
une force destructrice et parfois il y a
des vous grandissez avec des opinions
des avis sur ce que vous êtes sur ce que
vous faites sur à quoi vous ressemblez
et ce sont des avis qui sont négatifs et
ça vous influence toute votre vie vous
allez penser que vous n'avez pas un bel
physique que vous
vous êtes maladroit ou que vous pensez
pas correctement que vous devez changer
votre style de vivre et ça va vous
influencer ça va rentrer dans votre
système de croyance et ça va vous
transformer sans même vous rendre compte
la plupart du temps les gens ne se
rendent pas compte qu'ils sont très
influencés qui sont devenus quelqu'un
d'autre que c'est que ce qu'ils sentent
en réalité parce que ils sont ils ont
reçu ils ont hésité dans la réception de
des croyances des autres
donc ce que je suis pour moi est
multiple ce que je suis et ce que je
suis ce que je suis et ce que les autres
pensent que je suis et ce que je suis
c'est que ce que moi je pense être il ya
trois niveaux de la conscience de la
personne et si on maîtrise si on arrive
à voir les trois niveaux de cette
conscience de soi même je pense qu'on
peut se libérer et un des premiers
accords le premier accord des quatre
accords toltèques qui nous enseigne
beaucoup qui nous présente une un code
de conduite je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez les
les accords toltèques qu'est ce qu'il ya
dans la salle quelqu'un qui connaît la
lève la main par exemple les accords
toltèques la sagesse je ne vois pas tout
le monde malheureusement parce que j'ai
là le de la lumière dans les yeux mais
voilà donc le premier accord je vous
invite à aller découvrir les accords
toltèques le premier accord s'est fait
super fait que votre parole soit
impeccable
c'est à dire chaque fois que vous dit
quelque chose par rapport aux gens que
vous émettez un avis une opinion une
réaction
pensez à ce que vous dites parce que ce
que vous dites peut détruire qu'on peut
grandir quelqu'un très bien la
conscience du monde ma conscience de moi
même à travers ma conscience du monde
je pense que tous on veut tous les jours
changer quelque chose à soi c'est pour
cela on pense entre guillemets donner
une meilleure version ou travailler plus
ou changer tel défaut ou essayer de d2
dépasser telle faiblesse mais on demande
beaucoup de soin comment demande
beaucoup du monde et on demande beaucoup
parfois du monde plus qu'on demande de
soin est en réalité pour pour moi la
possibilité de voir évoluer les choses
c'est un travail personnel qui s'étend
sur un travail ou sur les rapports avec
les autres je dois être où je veux être
le changement que je je veux voir dans
le monde alors je travaille tous les
jours sur cela je suis à l'écouté je
suis ouverte
je suis attentive à ce qui se passe et
ma conscience qui est temps de venir
parce que ma conscience est prête à se
développer c'est c'est comme la
métaphore d'un caillou qui ont fait
tomber dans dans un lac et de ce choc
dieu caillou avec le lac
il y a des
cercle qui commence à se dessiner
jusqu'à couvrir toute la surface du lac
et c'est pareil pour moi la conscience
ce sont des petits efforts qu'ont qui
vont se mettre l'un à côté de l'autre
pour arriver à un grand éveil et le
grand éveil pour moi c'est de pouvoir
briser tous nous briser nos digues
briser nos peurs brisé nous nos craintes
briser notre déjà l'image qu'on se fait
de soi et l'image que les autres font de
nous et essayer de revenir à l'essentiel
dans l'homme quand j'étais petite je
rêvais de devenir je rêvais et je disais
même que je deviendrai le président de
la république est content je disais ça
tout le monde rigolait alors on aimait
bien me poser la question et ça me
rendait très très triste parce que je
voyais que les adultes se moquer
beaucoup d enfants et de leurs rêves
comme ça naïve peut-être certainement
maintenant que je suis adulte de dire
que en devenant président de la
république je peux changer le monde
plus tard j'ai fait j'ai commencé à
faire du théâtre
ça m'a fait beaucoup de bien et j'ai
commencé à créer du monde est monde
à l'intérieur de ce monde mais plus tard
quand j'ai eu à choisir pour ma carrière
pour les études que je dois suivre j'ai
choisi de faire des études juridiques et
politiques dans l'esprit de continuer
mon rêve d'enfant et ma première année
de faculté avec toutes les expériences
que j'ai fait dans le militantisme
politique j'ai dit ah non ça c'est pas
pour moi c'est pas comme ça que je peux
changer le monde
je préfère changer le monde à travers le
théâtre et j'ai dit maintenant moi je ne
fais plus de politique je fais du
poétique et je vais essayer de changer
le monde par l'art et dans mes pièces
donc mes créations dans mes livres je
cherche toujours à interroger le monde à
réfléchir à inviter les gens à réfléchir
avec moi mais la plupart du temps
j'étais aussi frustré ou je ne suis pas
satisfaite parce qu'autour de moi on me
renvoie cette image
mais comment ça se fait tuer avocat tu
travailles très peu tu ne gagnes pas cet
avis tu passes ton temps à être une
artiste dont la précarité à partir d'un
pays à un autre à courir
derrière des mirages et ça m'affecte
bien sûr et mais en même temps moi même
je me pose la question je me dis mais
comment je peux être utile pour les gens
ou pour mon pays
est ce qu'un poème peut guérir un malade
est-ce que je ne sais pas une pièce de
théâtre peut résoudre la guerre est ce
que parfois je suis je me sens comme
inutile et je suis je suis frustré mais
dans mes expériences j'ai eu la
possibilité aussi de comprendre que tout
ce qu'on fait à notre échelle tout petit
qu'il soit peut permettre du changement
dans le petit cercle qui va se
multiplier pour atteindre un cercle plus
grand et encore un centre le plus grand
et c'est comme ça c'est comme ça que le
changement que je veux être va devenir
le changement que je qui va qui va le
changement du monde et c'est pour cela
par exemple mon ami marcel moreau
l'auteur un superbe auteur belge m'a dit
qu'un jour elle était très affecté
qu'une lectrice vient le voir pour lui
dire qu'elle est guérie d'un concert
parce qu'elle a lu un livre de lui
j'ai une comédienne égyptienne qui
s'appelle y est maquillée elle a
travaillé avec moi sur une pièce sur les
femmes et elle m'a dit au bout d'un an
elle était elle n'était pas bien dans sa
peau avec sa féminité une femme une
femme dans le monde arabe et au bout
d'un an j'ai vu le changement radical
elle est revenue cette année on a joué
ou gtc en tunisie journées théâtrales de
carthage
elle était complètement changé en une
année elle est devenue complètement une
autre personne et c'est une pièce de
théâtre seulement une expérience d'une
pièce de théâtre
donc pour moi tout ce qu'on fait si
petit qu'il soit si on le fait vraiment
bien de tout notre volonté de faire avec
une grande conscience tout ce qu'on fait
il est il nous permet de nous améliorer
et d'améliorer tout ce qui se passe
autour de nous et je pour moi aussi ce
qui est important c'est que c'est que on
ne devient pas l'autre qu'on a décidé
pour nous ce qui est important c'est de
rester soi même est
soi même et pas un autre et c'est ça le
plus grand défi en réalité parce qu'être
les autres c'est facile il y a des
ready-made chemin à faire et on est tous
comme les autres et je vais finir par
une citation extraordinaire j'aurais pas
tout dit j'ai beaucoup de choses à dire
mais c'est les auteurs ils sont toujours
très bavards les avocats aussi un
superbe
auteur aussi que j'aime beaucoup raoul
vaneigem si je prononçais très bien son
nom je ne sais pas il dit soit ce que tu
désires de sorte que chaque désir
accroissent la vie en toi et moi je vous
souhaite d'être toujours ce que vous
désiriez de sorte que le shaq désir
accroissent la vie en vous je vous
remercie